Now let's go back to the phases within a cycle.
because I want to show you how they relate to traditional
activities of software development. Because this is the first time that
we talk about inception, elaboration, construction and transition. So we will
know what they mean, in terms of the traditional software
development. So I'm going to first discuss these relations and then
I'm going to talk about each individual phase in further detail.
So I'm going to start by representing the four RUP phases here
with possible internal iterations. I1, E1 and E2, C1,
C2, and so on. And just as a reference, this
is the way in which time will progress. So we
will start with inception and we will finish with transition.
So what I'm want to do now is to show the
actual, traditional, software development activities here on the left. And
I also want to show you, using this diagram, how these
activities are actually performed in each of the RUP phases.
So, let's see what this representation means. Basically, what
I'm showing here, is that requirements engineering actually starts in
the inception phase. So, you can see the height
of this bar as the amount of effort devoted to
this activity in this specific phase. So you can
see that requirements engineering starts in inception phase, is mostly
performed in the elaboration phase, and then it continues,
although to a lesser extent, throughout all phases up until
the end of the transition. But the bulk is really
performed here in the elaboration phase. Similarly, if we consider analysis
and design, we can see that analysis and design are
mainly performed in the elaboration phase. But a considerable amount of
it also continues in the construction phase, and then it
kind of phases out. So there's very little of that done
in the transition phase. Looking now at implementation, you can see
that the implementation happens mostly in the construction phase, which is,
unsurprisingly, the phase that is mostly concerned with actual code development,
as we will see in a minute. Testing, on the other
hand, is performed throughout most phases, with, peaks in some specific
point, for example, at the end of some iterations, like here
and here. To conclude, we have the business modeling activity that
happens mainly in the inception and a little bit in the
elaboration phase and the deployment activity which happens a little bit
throughout, but the bulk of it is really in the transition
phase, which is actually the phase that has to do
with deployment and then maintenance. So I hope this kind
of high level view gives you a better understanding of
what is the mapping between these new phases and, the
typical software development activities that we are more familiar with.
So to further this understanding, later in the lesson, I'm
also going to talk about these specific phases individually. First, however,
I want to spend a little more time discussing what happens
inside each one of these iterations, just to make sure
that we are all understand what an iteration is exactly.